Hi everyone.
Welcome to told her cubicle.
I'm delighted to introduce today's speaker.
Doctor,
how are you Barry?
[inaudible]
hey,
did everybody,
um,
great turnout and hopefully now you get something out of this today.
Why don't I go to talk about today is the difference between the anxiety and
panic and wine.
Does anxieties become a problem in our lives?
A modern view of anxiety and panic?
The role of our stress system or a logic and emotion brands.
Uh,
key players and anxiety and panic.
And then we're going to go straight into what a panic attacks.
How'd you deal with him?
Hoss?
General anxiety.
How to deal with it.
What social anxiety.
How to deal with phobias.
That's a prayer of it,
isn't it?
I'm going to move,
I gotta move along at speed.
Is that okay?
So here's the question for everybody present.
How many of you suffer from anxiety?
You are a very good growth because at least a few.
You were brave enough to put up your hands.
Okay,
here's the test for everybody.
Yep.
Sorry.
Eh,
here's,
I did a test for everybody.
I want you to close your eyes and for 30 seconds take of the most embarrassing
thing that ever happened to you,
the most shameful,
the most off.
The thing you don't want anybody else in the room to note is that,
okay,
why don't you pick this?
I ain't going to walk up and down
and I'm going to ask you.
You've got to pick somebody out and you're going to have to stand up.
Is that okay?
You're going to have to tell everybody in the audience.
That's most embarrassing thing.
Is that okay?
We always had,
this is always wonderful because people aren't tying to look away or look up,
look down because everybody is going to feel ashamed and embarrassed.
Isn't that right?
Okay,
so I'm going to pick somebody I think from over here we're like,
well,
maybe I'll go over here
anyway.
Good year.
As far as,
I'm not going to ask you a tour today,
the most embarrassing thing in your life,
but hands up.
Anybody who taught who got anxious that I might come on.
Okay.
No,
I think that's very important because we all get anxious,
don't fee.
And the first big message of today is that anxiety as normal.
But how did you feel physically?
Did you all feel,
notice your heart going back quicker,
stomach more or better?
Not God,
I hope it doesn't take me.
The reason for that is because as human beings we hit to be embarrassed,
but that's how you feel when you're anxious.
So I think it's important that anxiety is a normal human emotion that relates to
very much worrying about what's going to happen in the future.
Whilst I going to ask her,
fear is very much about the acute sense of the here and no sense of dread in
here and know somebody of you were probably panicking a little bit there,
then I might ask you.
But I think,
well,
both of these emotions are quite healthy and appropriate.
For example,
if I'm afraid I'm gonna lose my job,
I'm going to be doing a lot of worrying.
So I'm going to be very anxious.
If I meet a mugger,
I'm going be very panicky.
So I'm going to be very fearful.
So I think these become a problem in our lives though.
The plan to become co,
you know,
really chronic and pervasive,
uh,
and fun.
There's no real danger and they're often accompanied by this serious of physical
symptoms.
And if there's one big message I want to get across today is the physical nature
of anxiety and they think what's important was when we get anxious is we all try
to avoid like you've all looked away and that was your natural instinct because
you didn't want to be picked on.
So our natural behavior is safety,
behavior avoidance behavior,
and they take,
in modern Ireland,
we're seeing the huge increase in boarding zygosity and panic and a game changer
for result,
to be honest,
has been the smart phone and social media that has massively increased the
national sense of anxiety and panic.
And I think it's not,
it's not unfair to say that we're all living and some of us unfortunately are
dying in the world of continuous rating,
which goes on as a result of social media.
I think the modern approach to understanding anxiety and panic is that all of
us,
through a combination of genes,
upbringings,
and general life occurrences end up with becoming,
having these pathways in our brain,
which become fairly fixed as we're growing and developing and our mind and our
brand partners get interwoven each feeding on the other.
As we'll see later,
therapy's all about trying to change those pathways and we call this capacity of
the brain to change neuroplasticity,
the ability to change.
So what's quite extraordinary is the capacity of each person here to change your
brain pathways to positive ones.
And the mind itself,
believe it or not,
is the generator that we use to change those patterns.
So this really opens up the very exciting possibility that we can use our mind
to reshape the very brand pathways which are causing the problems for us in.
So we're no longer slaves of the past,
but we can learn how to modify these brain pathways,
which caused so much difficulties with panic attacks,
general anxiety,
social anxiety and phobias.
And this is best done with CVT.
Would you like to do a first bit of neuroscience?
Okay.
This is for neuroscience with for dummies.
Is that okay?
We're going to do it in a cup to seconds.
So we're going to do a bit of quick neuroscience or mood.
A mood system in the brain is basically control composed of four parts.
The frontal we'll fee component of which is our prefrontal cortex or our logical
brain or limbic mood department,
which is our emotional brain or adrenal stress land and Duka Cortisol,
our stress hormone,
which all make up the word flag.
So believe it or not,
that's what your brand looks like.
Pretty,
pretty.
Pretty York isn't just,
uh,
but at the front of your brain is about a tardy or brand is called the
prefrontal cortex.
And there's some key areas here.
The logic box is what you use a lot here in Google,
a lot of rationality,
uh,
and also,
attention bucks as the party is.
And today when you're looking at me,
um,
the emotional control box and social control boxes is very much about how we
manage our emotions and control our social behavior.
But our prefrontal Cortex,
our logical brain,
just think of it as your logical brain.
It's in charge of reasoning,
logic,
analysis,
planning and creativity.
It's how we can treat,
create and control and mood is very important in how he controlled behavior,
particularly impulsive self destructive behaviors such as self harm or suicide
and very,
very important in how we uh,
we live in our social world and very important for empathy.
That's what your emotion,
that's what your emotional brain looks like is called your limbic system.
It's in the middle of your brain,
a very old part of the brand and as you can see there are a couple of key areas
there.
The memory box is called your hippocampus dust where you actually organize all
your memories.
The islands and area called the insula distress box.
We'd be talking a lot about today.
It's called the Amygdala and the pleasure box is called the nucleus accumbens.
But basically your emotional brain is controlling your stress system is how we
process our emotions.
Negative emotions like fear,
sadness,
anger,
how we store it and retrieve memories and how we enjoy food,
sex and alcohol or this is the really the more important part of the slide,
which is the bigger arrow.
It's the one going for our emotion.
Brand is a to our logical brain,
and this is really important because for years it was taught that are irrational
brain or logical brain,
our prefrontal cortex as much more powerful,
but we now realize there's far more connections going from emotional brain to
our logical brain and in reverse.
Now,
this is critical for mental health.
I would probably say after it was a single slide,
I was asked to shoulder to actually explain mental health.
This is it.
That one slide there,
very simple slide,
but actually that's the key.
That very simple slide there because when we're well,
our emotions and our logic are in harmony.
For example,
a promo going by our favorite Chinese restaurant or Italian restaurant,
and we're three or four stone of weight and are a rational brand,
says for God's sake,
we not going to here you'd have to die more richer emotional brand smells the
food which wins of course your emotional wreck or it's three in the morning and
you're referred your girlfriend or your boyfriend flogging ran,
freeze and cold,
and your rational brain says,
for God's sake when you get out of here for getting pneumonia,
but your emotional brain would say Lemoore.
Okay,
I hope
we'd be worried.
So I think what's really important is that every decision we make during the day
is a k in the dance of life is a kind of a combination of emotion and logic.
But when we unfortunately get into difficulties with anxiety,
depression,
self harm,
what actually happened is that our emotional brain turns negative on us and when
it turns negative,
it's swamps her logical brand.
And that's when all the fun begins.
So very quickly we're going to have a look at the stress system.
Very important distress system is critical for anxiety and the stress system's
job is to look for danger,
any kind of immediate danger or perceived trash and basically pick up on that
danger and physically prepare the body to fire to get ready for that danger.
And it's crazy can function is to protect us and not harmless.
And if you can understand this simple idea,
we don't understand almost everything to do with anxiety.
This is a very simple slide for it simply shows distress boxes of literary
called the Mega,
which we'll be talking about in a minute.
Uh,
basically supposed to be calm under acute stress.
I your boss's college,
you mentioned you're not sure what the hell they've done wrong and suddenly you
find that you're pumping out adrenaline.
Noradrenaline would be if you're going to get aggressive with them,
which is very unlikely,
Adrenalin is going to be,
uh,
if you're,
if you're feeling a bit fearful about the interview and what happens is
adrenaline needs our fear of harm when we talk about that in a minute.
But so both were under some chronic or persistent stress.
Well.
Then we start,
which is a chronic stress home,
which is took a cortisol.
And this is the guide that leads to so many difficulties in our lives.
So I'm going to talk about these and foster distress system.
It's called the Amygdala.
And this is an order,
this is a great friend of mine because uh,
uh,
I had a great conversation verbatim and great discussions with people about him.
Now it's a very ancient Oregon buried in your emotional brand and it's hard to
believe that this guy was round in Italian,
the dinosaur.
So before man came into being at all the Amygdala,
it was firing.
So it senses danger,
it fires,
and it activates the rest of your stress system.
And it activates that.
It releases adrenaline and mainly so adrenaline is our fear.
Harmon.
So I think you'll find from,
we go to panic attacks,
how important this is.
So our fear hormones very much involved in a,
I'm going to give you a,
a story.
When I was in Africa matter leopard,
and I'm not joking at three in the morning there,
they didn't believe you.
But the shot from the following day.
So when I met the leopard,
what saved my life was the Amygdala there,
saw the leopard before I did.
I froze.
And suddenly my heart is pounding.
I was shaking,
I was sweating,
I couldn't breed,
uh,
at my musters role tense.
My mouth was dry and a disturbed sense of dread.
In fact,
what do make it Lou was doing was getting me ready to do a runner.
So if my heart went faster,
I would run quicker.
If my stomach was in knots and the blood was taken notes and send to my muscles,
they'd run faster and motorists,
dre or the bloods or subtotal in Bozeman central and muscles and run faster.
And we can all identify with those symptoms when we get acutely stressed.
But if the dangerous end scene is more chronic,
uh,
we ended up succeeding more,
of course,
which is our retirement,
where it hormone,
which we'll talk about it.
So there's some lovely facts about the Amygdala and you'll see why these are
very important.
They wrong.
First thing about is I call them the gunslinger because he's trend from the time
of the day and is hard to draw and fire instantly.
So He's razor sharp.
He's a gunslinger second that he's ticket the wall.
And actually once you understand that if you make tick as the wall,
you can get rid of panic attacks very quickly.
Once you get it,
you understand this guys take it away.
I didn't get rid of a lot of phobias,
so I think he doesn't do talk to her,
but he's not particularly interested.
You can't have a chart for him.
He didn't have a chat with me when I'm at a leopard and say,
what do you think we should do?
He just fired his along memory for fear or danger.
That's the big problem.
Once he remembers the danger,
he'd remember it the next time and the next times it gets stronger and stronger.
He's also counterintuitive in that you can't listen.
You can't talk to them.
Do using all of northern techniques.
So just to finish with the neuroscience,
but our prefrontal cortex is very important in this regulates our stress system
and really important that when we're anxious,
the rate side of our brain,
the prefrontal cortex is where we catastrophize what's going to happen.
And the left side is the warrior.
And really important is that the right side has a straight link to the
gunslinger.
So the more we could testify about something,
the more we've immortal fires.
So let's,
let's go on a dare the key players and anxiety,
then the Amygdala in the center.
When you're acutely anxious,
you'd treats the adrenaline as release Adrenalin when you're chronically
anxious,
who released the took of course.
So when you're worrying all the time,
you're using the left side of your brand and when you're catastrophizing,
you're using the right side of the brain.
So these are the anxiety disorders that we're going to deal with very quickly.
Panic attacks for his social anxiety and a bit of general anxiety.
So imagine John Sitting at home reading the paper when he suddenly feels his
horse pony shaking.
Sweating is breathing faster,
is terrible.
Things that dread his weakness is truck closing in and he thinks it's all over.
It's never happened to him before and he served is going today.
So welcome John to the word of panic attacks.
And this is really,
really come.
I had one man,
he was actually watching a cartoon show.
He would laugh in a way and two minutes later even the middle of a panic attack
full blown.
So these are very common,
up to 8% of the population will have at least one in their lifetime,
but 5% of the population would have recurrent homes.
I think what's important that they can be associated with general anxiety,
depression and addiction,
but frequently occur in the role.
They can occur in any situation at any time.
And that's what the problem lies.
So the fear of getting them,
which we call panic disorder,
is actually the biggest single problem.
So we not only have to worry about the panic attack,
but we worry about will.
I would have happened in front of my workmates when it happened,
when emotional,
the party would,
it happened in front of my friends.
But it happened in the shopping center.
So people begin to dread these symptoms.
So these are typically kind of symptoms which you've already gone through,
but a really important point that far the person,
there's no obvious trigger so they can see what started to panic attack.
The guy was watching a comedy,
some cartoons,
so what and Garth name triggered it.
But the good news is that they're actually caused by the gunslinger firing back
to my friend.
You make to it because it senses a danger,
releases adrenaline from the adrenal gland which pours into your,
into your body,
giving you all of these extreme,
the horrible,
comfortable physical symptoms.
So they,
the secret really is that the trigger is the first physical symptom that we feel
and what happens then is our catastrophizing mine stars and maybe individualize
it as something terrible is going to happen.
And the things that people most often,
it's unbelievably how constant is it?
Because I have dealt with,
I would here to tell you,
you know how many people have dealt with and these days they will always come
back to these dangers.
Here,
I'm going to have a heart attack,
stroke collapse or day and go to,
I'm going to completely lose control and run amok and going to call mad or
people who seen me.
So these are the dangers that the person has.
So they interpret their for these initial symptoms as dangerous demand their
stuff.
And of course the more that you demand this stuff,
the worst to get.
And then port causes all the trouble is our safety behavior because what do
people do at panic attack to head off to the [inaudible],
to leave the area,
to take tranquilizers,
to try breathing exercises there,
trade,
most of all to stop the physical symptoms.
And of course the board are used and the more they trade his behavior,
the worse it gets.
So I think what's causing it,
what's really important is that the physical symptoms of anxiety that you
experienced during a panic attack or uncomfortable but not dangerous,
that's the key to them to are best treated with CBT.
A one,
a request to have his daughter's tranquilizers because if he was tranquilized
your stuff,
do you Megla from changing its memory does a much simpler way to get rid of the
void.
Antidepressants cause people are proud of 90 presses all the time for this and
as a total waste of time,
uh,
never try and stop a panic attack.
That's what everybody goes wrong.
They tried to stop the attack and the visualization I give to people is imagine
you could go into the sea,
put up your hand and try and stop to tight.
That's what it's like to trap botanic tag because when you get to when the
gunslinger fires and adrenaline rush is going to happen with the election or
not.
So we known all that.
If you do nothing in the past,
in 10 minutes,
if he tracks stuff,
it'll take up to an hour.
So the modern neuroscience has shown us that if we use a concept called flooding
that had actually clears and flooding as this extraordinary concept where we
actually visually get the person to visualize that are stuck to the chair at the
CAC,
go into Europe.
And a panic attack strokes.
They're not allowed to do anything but to have to visualize that the panic
attack weaves these horrible physical symptoms flood over them.
And actually what happened is,
but they don't try to stop them.
And what happens is the gunslinger changes as memory at that moment in time.
One stick guns thing,
a realizes that you're not as saying your danger,
he actually changes.
And actually from Dan on the next time it happens as much lesser and the
negative ended after that.
Scott.
So what we actually do is we get people to understand that these symptoms are
not dangerous.
There are simply a normal bodily adrenaline rush.
There are uncomfortable about Dante.
And so you give the person the choice of fears and to discomforted using
flooding or running from panic attacks for the rest of your life.
And this is so successful that we would hear,
I'd say 95% of panic attacks in one session,
maybe Max two sections.
And that's something that's not,
that's not an age of step.
And no,
we are genuinely cleared.
We've had people with panic attacks up to 30 years and cheered them and maybe
one or two sessions.
Okay.
Happy with that.
General anxiety,
uh,
is where we get,
these are where people,
mainly women are more warriors and they've constant in bursts of intense anxiety
and worry about health,
family jobs and the key to us that you have a constant sense for board and
they're both some impending disaster,
your daughter,
what the hell it is but it,
but it's there all the time and just constant catastrophizing for what might
happen.
And the Tinder causes the real problem or role the,
the physical symptoms because you get mental and physical symptoms.
You've got things like urge of above.
These are kind of constant ones.
Pro Concentration and memory,
sleep difficulties,
nightmares in decisiveness,
difficulty coping,
uh,
avoiding everyday task because you want to have them done perfectly.
Muscle tension,
teak ranging.
Uh,
very funny,
I deleted her recently and I was going through the thing of the symptoms about
any teeth grinding and she started to laugh because she had,
she had the garden place from the dentist.
So really common,
uh,
and increase risk of panic attacks.
And I think,
uh,
I think what's important is about two or three,
we'll have at least one episode of depression and are like,
but what's really important for women,
this matters for women particularly,
is that many,
many people use alcohol to try and corporate us because the order you get,
the worse it gets.
And if you don't deal with it properly,
you started to use things like garlic and lots of women news way.
I'd say the number one treatment for general anxiety monster,
which is why,
and therefore lots of women become increasingly hooked on wine.
So it's a really important to stay.
In the old days,
lots of people got hooked on tranquilizers.
Thankfully that's not as much any longer.
And they think it's important that we get,
we get anxious because of these genetic and earned very much environmental
partners that are set down,
uh,
when we're growing and developing.
And I think the key physical thing in the in,
in general anxiety is that the right side of your brain and his catastrophizing
and the left side is worry and Baltar into a lot of cortisol being released.
Took a course on Duke.
A car is the guy just giving you the tired but wired feeling the teeth grinding
and all of these physical symptoms at night.
I did treatment is holistic exercise,
nutrition,
Yoga,
Oliver,
all of a role,
I think CBT is really good.
Trey,
if you can't avoid use of antidepressants because in general they're not
necessary and the vast majority of cases they actually really worse than the
issue.
CBT.
I do it at the end.
Is that a CBT?
CBT,
cognitive behavior therapy.
Okay.
I give you an exact believe or not.
When I went through the panic attacks,
which are,
I was actually giving you a cognitive behavioral therapy exercises.
I'm not interesting.
You've already had some.
Okay.
Okay,
so what are we doing in CBT,
which is that we try to reshape the person's tinkering under behavior.
So,
in other words,
the thinking behind general anxiety is a demand for control.
So if there's one word that describes general anxiety is the person who wants to
be in control.
The person who wants to get everything done perfectly,
everything,
all of us on time,
one to control every facet of their life.
So while we had to do is challenge that whole demand for control and they also
have a great tendency to catastrophize.
So we have to teach them skills,
how to do that.
But particularly we have to go after it or behavior because a lot of people end
up spending avoidant behavior.
So the typical example would be you have a job to do and you want it done
perfectly and you're so anxious about doing it that you keep delaying putting it
off and then it gets closer and closer to the time and has to get done.
But you're getting more and more anxious.
So actually it ends up and you incredibly anxious doing it at the last minute,
uh,
and,
and feeling more anxious then this,
you haven't done a property.
So it kind of builds on itself.
I always use the example of where I get into trouble with the girls.
Can I do this of imagining having the [inaudible] branch or maybe I'll do it,
maybe I'll do it tomorrow and then tomorrow comes along and says,
maybe I limited it to tomorrow and suddenly you have a pile of our own and go on
and you wonder how in Gallon home hell am I ever going to start and stuff.
So you know it.
That's just the kind of world live person,
maternal anxiety,
social anxiety is another common,
really disabling the condition.
This is for a person suffers from constant social anxiety in social situations
there for a period of greater than six months.
The secret here is that her experience,
a sense of being judged and being judged harshly by yachters and feeling
embarrassed by their own actions and social situations.
And I think what's important that they're are also accompanied by a lot of
physical symptoms like blushing,
sweating your mind,
going blank,
stammering and unlike ball sort of phobias,
continuous exposure to people doesn't make it any better.
And they think the critical thing is that most people end up avoiding social
situations.
And I,
I've had lots of young people who for example,
is struggling to go into relationships and the reason they're struggling with,
into relationships because when they go into a social situation and are so
anxious and so embarrassed that they don't know what to do.
The lovely thing is that within four or five sessions we can get people back to
normal tobacco socialize.
My Day was made one day when this lovely young man had done about four sessions
and he came in and shook my hand and he said,
cause he had struggled even to even to talk to a girl.
He said,
I know and I have a debt.
Good.
I said we had done it.
Okay.
Okay,
so there are two kinds of social anxiety performance situations.
This is where like somebody like myself doing this,
becoming credibly anxious because I'm acutely aware of what you'd think of me,
which I am of course social interaction situations for we want to be out
involved say in meeting people at a party and things like that.
So these are typical social interactions,
situations where you might have to initiate a conversation,
meet some strangers,
go to parties,
meet people over for dinner.
Meeting friends in the pub is a nightmare for a person with social anxiety
that's been ours beforehand.
Preparing,
expressing a personal opinions are being assertive or talking to people in
authority and these are typical performance situations.
Public speaking,
speaking in front of a class as eating,
drinking,
believe or not being in the restroom.
Some people would get incredibly anxious that people would get zero observing
them in the restaurant,
which is very scary.
King sports in front of voters.
I had a lovely example of a lad who is brought to me,
very good tennis player and everybody taught that he was not performing because
he was so anxious that he would,
he would do it perfectly,
but it wasn't fun and got everybody out of the room.
His problem was that he was so upset that people would see him sweating on the
court,
that he couldn't perform,
not interesting to nothing.
So when we clear that that was the end of that,
um,
being caught out or making mistakes and the presence of others.
So typically taught in the social situation might be,
I have nothing interesting to say and people would think I'm boring.
That's the great word and I hope nobody,
you've see me blushing or sweating cause that's what everybody is afraid of.
What an extraordinary set.
And they'll see that an anxious in my eyes or my face and I hope nobody can see
how anxious are young because if they do,
they'll think I'm weak and dust.
The key to social anxiety,
people think that we're weak
and these are kind of typical behaviors.
Would you like me to go to what happens to a person to go to a party?
Cause this is a classic example.
It's so it starts maybe a couple of hours beforehand and this art,
the rehearsing,
they check themselves in the mirror.
How do I look too?
I look anxious to am I blushing,
am I sweating?
And then they start rehearsing.
What am I going to say?
And what would people,
what would be a good thing that are kind of topic if I were to bring it up at a
social situation and then they get down to the parity or to the local club if
the guy is more so than we go straight for the,
for the,
for the birds,
it's thread thread for a pint.
Uh,
most of the girls would go to the restroom and check on my blushing and
sweating.
And then,
uh,
from that people were then stare at the,
at the bare basic to the exit.
People will spend a little bit of time maybe trying to stay away from the center
of the crowd.
Really try not to initiate conversations.
And if they do,
try and rehearse what to go,
going to say before to say it,
and then go home to go home to do a post mortem.
She's upon a nightmare,
not a nightmare.
And that's only just going down to the local pub.
And that happens every solitary social situation.
So the great thing about this is to be completely clear very,
very quickly.
So it's caused by,
believe it or not,
the same old gunslinger as the cause of death.
He's a reload character,
this guy.
And basically what he's doing,
he has learned to misread faces.
And it happens usually as a result of something that happens in our childhood
where we say we're mid of fool of or marked in some way in some public
situation,
either in a family situation,
very often at school or in some public situation.
So our amygdala begins to misfire and misread faces.
And the key again is the old cbts cause again.
And the good news,
we can challenge the irrational belief and an unhealthy behaviors very quickly
with in social anxiety.
So the key for the danger for the socially anxious person,
this is what we're worried about,
is that people will see it or anxious.
Uh,
and if it's public speaking,
let's see,
they're anxious and clam up and lose track of earlier and then everybody would
judge him as weak and there's a failure and they weren't 100% certainty that
everything Moscow well,
uh,
and that nothing can go wrong and they can never come up.
So the first thing I get them to,
to,
to understand is that we all came up,
we all do is track for giving talks.
It was the norm.
So we challenged our safe to be here,
which is always to check,
check and double check.
But the socially anxious person had social situations is what they're worried
about.
The people will see all these physical symptoms of anxiety.
They will see them blushing,
sweating,
believe or not.
Some people would wear an extra jacket on even though it's very warm in the,
uh,
in the pub.
Rather than see people,
people's might see this sweat and their constant checking with the blushing and
sweating.
So to me in a note to the restroom to check for that,
but they have as an exaggerated picture of how bad any of these are.
And they struggle often with conversation exercises.
This is a key thing.
One of the things I teach people this conversation exercises to try and have
them overcome things.
So what we have to do is challenged our thinking and our behavior.
And we have these,
I'm not going to tell you what they are cause they're a secret.
We call them embarrassment exercises and they're just fantastic.
I am not joking.
I have seen grown men wilt and say I can't do that.
I just counted up and this was like this if you want to get better than when I
was two.
So actually these,
these wonderful embarrassment exercise are incredibly powerful at actually
getting rid of social anxiety.
And we can clear it in a couple of sessions very quick.
And uh,
the,
the lovely thing about them is that by the end I get rid of person.
Social anxieties is a better way and kind of have them understanding one
important thing.
That word,
none of us are to some partners.
We take pair
that interesting.
So once I get them to realize we're nice,
important,
we think we are an approach to this has been a sense of humor is their home and
drag.
Okay.
Have you already had enough where they do four years pretty quickly?
I we short to two minutes.
Okay.
Right.
Phobias as two very quick.
A phobia.
Simply an excessive fear of being exposed to a situation or a to toy.
You think you're going to get incredibly anxious.
So these are typical ones.
We all know the animals and insects ones.
Uh,
what lots of people probably are also aware that when you're exposed to
situation in that confined space is crowds open spaces,
mortar where's for example are a huge issue,
lifts,
plans,
blood,
et cetera.
So people got all these phobias about these things and they literally will not
go on the motorway.
They walk with hospitals because of blood.
The Walk to end two lifts at the fuse to go into churches and shopping centers
and all the rest of it.
I grew up phobias where,
uh,
we've become a fear of open spaces.
Uh,
and it comes from the Greek word meaning I Gora which means open spaces.
So I think their treatment is really to be on the CVT is the best way to treat
them.
And now it's,
it doesn't work.
And the media part thing about a phobia phobia is a red herring.
Is that,
do you know what a red herring,
it's a red herring.
It's like a false trail.
And the real problem is that people think that the plane is the phobia or
they've lifted the phobia or the shopping Sandra to port.
It's not,
it's walked up,
I think is going to happen when I'm exposed to it.
And that's to see for me,
I,
it's actually,
I think it's going to happen,
isn't going to get incredibly anxious when you teach people how to deal with
that because it's exactly the same as having a panic attack.
But even at very similar response to,
again,
the guns are firing in exactly the same way.
So when you teach people how to deal with that and exposed them to the forming,
you've turned up very quickly.
So I would come,
any of people who come to me with two or three,
four years.
But the good news for you is if you can learn how to deal with one phobia,
you deal with them all cause the same process truth.
I think that's basically all that I am going to talk with [inaudible] I was in
Qa now,
uh,
I think just for your own interest if flagging is actually a panic is probably
sit available in some shops around in the past I've seen there's a KFC here and
there and we are doing another reprint.
And uh,
it w it will be very available.
There's all to four year,
two videos,
which have been,
uh,
very much watched by many,
many people which go along with the book.
And it's very interesting.
One that I've also did with panic away,
which has been seen by something like 330,000 papers or something like that at
to stage on panic attacks.
I'm not interesting around the world.
So really important.
Okay.
All right,
great.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for your attention.
I was going to
detail talk,
I think you actually answered a lot of my questions is shuffling them letter my
seat there and trying to think of so,
so new ones.
Um,
something that you and I have spoken about in the past,
which I'd love you to explain to our audience a bit more is the science behind
why people might wake up feeling anxious.
So this is very,
very interesting.
One and many,
many people come to me with general anxiety.
And the first thing they say to me,
there's,
I could open the morning and I wake up in the morning and before I can even
start taking about today,
I find my stomach is nuts.
I'm feeling very tense,
my muscles are tense,
my heart baby going bit quicker and I feel loved.
MNEMONIC can I kind of work out what's actually happening?
So it was actually very separate when you experienced them.
So what's actually happening is when we're asleep,
we dream for the last four hours,
particularly of the theater or a cycle that's we do most of our dreaming.
And as for the close,
we get to waking up the more dreaming we do,
we call this rem sleep,
which is rapid eye movement sleep because that's what happens when you're,
so all that's happening in,
in,
in rem sleep is that we're reorganizing our memories for her to date of the date
of the previous day.
So what happens is the two key players in that are the hippocampus,
which is your memory box and the Amygdala,
which as you've gone slimmer,
so what actually is happening in the brain,
the brain is actually creating almost a literal story.
As all of these memories I've been bounced back,
back and forth,
all of everything that happened during the day,
uh,
creating almost like a little story for it.
So you for example,
[inaudible] had been shared through the first or something like that in your,
in your mind,
but you don't remember any of this.
But what actually happens is the gunslinger is firing full blast just as if you
were awake during those periods.
So actually what actually happens is you wake up,
you have no memory of the actual dream but the gunslinger is affects the
Adrenalin effects are still going on.
Well actually we started to do dentists.
We started to,
Oh God,
it must be something terrible's going to happen today.
So no,
I started to visualize what's going to have to do and then I really make myself
access ivory.
And the reason by the way had the guns thing or is so active in general anxiety
it's cause it's active during the day cause we're constantly worrying all the
time.
So it's more a worry in the data and the more you're going to worry at
nighttime.
But the trouble is,
I don't remembers,
I know you also mentioned that sometimes there's filing of the anxieties that
we've had throughout the day can sometimes reawakened a memory or an experience
in the past.
Yes.
Yes,
exactly.
Like I for example,
if I do have a memory of something negative that happened to be from my dream
during the night,
it new re re re re establish the order pattern again.
But I think the,
the important part is that the gunslinger is,
it's a secret.
If you can learn to understand the physical nature of anxiety,
you'll never worry about anxiety again because that's actually what really
causes the problem.
It's the,
it's the physical side.
And we don't understand.
People don't understand the worrying,
they understand the catastrophize,
but they just don't get that it's a physical condition.
But the wonderful thing about that is that the Amygdala,
his as the wall results completely manageable.
You can put manners on them very quickly if you know what to do.
It's when you don't understand them that you have a problem.
That's the one way.
Maybe I'm putting some manners on an errand.
And do you have any,
uh,
everybody analogy in your book holds spilled milk?
Both spoke.
Yes.
Yeah.
Tell us about that.
So if I ask you about what do you visualize when you visualize Belzberg,
can somebody tell me what your baseline is when your peers racialized?
Anybody want to share?
I heard a man mess.
Smell,
smell horrible.
You can see it in the car first and the mass and the MOCHA.
Okay.
So what I actually say to a person as well,
suppose I took the tiniest drop of milk and put it on the table.
Would that also be his best book?
Of course.
But while we do instinctively is via visualize the drop as the pudding.
So it's a wonderful technique and CBT,
which is that if you're catastrophizing about something,
you go to Japan and paper and you have to prove on paper that you're
catastrophizing is true.
And why that's so important is to remember that I was showing you that the area
of the brain called the logic bucks.
Do you know what I been purchase your,
you're the,
the rational part.
It's the,
it's the executive brand at the,
it's called the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex.
But this guy has the job,
I'll put manners on everything else in the brand.
So when you write things down,
it gets involved and you know,
have to rationally explain to him,
imagine your expand to your boss.
Do you know what I mean?
That all this catastrophizing,
it's true.
And of course you can't.
So the minute that happens with them,
you drop as Pittsburgh and actually it's a great way of teaching years have
actually done,
is it a real problem or is it just a visualized problem and 90% of the time or
the way it's a visual as well.
That's right.
Yeah.
Don't ask him.
Uh,
just one more question before I open up to some audience questions.
Um,
there's been,
it's been a pretty big sea change in Ireland over the last number of years
regarding this topic amongst the general public.
Well,
so,
uh,
you've mentioned to me there's been some changes to the GP trainees.
Yeah.
I think what's happening is most of the older gps,
almost a grandfather dies or the state,
uh,
but most of the order gps would not have had the benefit of,
um,
mental health techniques.
Do you know what I mean?
But no,
the,
the assessment trainees or the dealer,
the trainee gps who are being trained to be general practitioners are a tank for
the being exposed to what the cause is,
CBT concepts and techniques.
So it doesn't necessarily mean that they will,
all of us have the time or the energy or the space to,
to use to,
but at least they have a much better understanding of them.
Do you know what I mean?
Which is I think a way of the food.
But one of my big things is I actually believe that there's a big problem
nowadays that we all believe we need an expert.
We do any fear to go to the toilet.
We nearly need to have an expert who tend to get us to the titles.
In reality,
we all have a wonderful in the personal resilience skills,
but what we need is information and knowledge and techniques.
So what I would really appeal to,
everybody has read,
read books like this.
Do you know what I mean?
Develop these techniques in yourself and they can,
you can be enormously helpful to other people in order to be in.
If you have these,
uh,
tactics herself,
and people in your family.
Really important to me that we need to be resilient.
You know,
and what I I'd love to do is I'd have to do a rating thing.
Could I do a reading thing?
Can I do,
would you like data rate and game?
Right?
Okay.
I want you to visualize if you have a piece of paper you can do it or otherwise
visualize in your head,
um,
uh,
align straightline with one at one and a 100 or the other end.
Is that okay?
Can you visualize that?
Okay.
Now I want you to give yourself one is your crap and a hundred days you're the
bee's knees.
Is that okay?
So I want you to give yourself a rating between one and a hundred.
You don't,
okay?
At global rating.
No.
I want you to visualize for other people,
rich,
this is your chance.
They really think I'm the bee's knees.
Okay?
We'll be all done that.
Now I'm going to give you a few situations.
You're diagnosed with depression and you put on antidepressants and word cause I
told your friends and colleagues,
where do you register at a time?
I'm where do,
where do you visualize other people who were rich?
Okay,
let's take another situation.
You're,
you're a real high flyer out to job and then you're fired and suddenly your uh,
financial situation,
it takes a nose dive and your mortgage is not in trouble,
you know,
fighting with your partner.
Would you rate up then
I remember with dozers,
Reggie.
Okay.
But some people I do.
Your social media is actually a trans people take care of.
Just yuck.
Where would you rate yourself then?
Where do you think others would rate you?
Interesting.
There's game isn't it?
Now?
Hands up.
Anybody who did,
who you didn't change the rating
when you are not as group.
Is that okay?
Cause we all played this game.
We called it to raise again,
don't treat it.
We spent our lives raising each other and raising ourselves and this is what
causes so much problems and mental health because one of the big problems and
anxiety is that we're spending all our time reading.
I said so can be Retros House.
Is it possible to raise ourselves?
Can we raise the sense,
can we read to give a d?
No,
it's actually,
it's actually a trick because in real life is there any skill that we can
actually use that can rate ourselves the rest of children.
So in reality,
uh,
we,
I asked her to join the Ragga dog club and raggy dog club is,
is,
is a wonderful case of which I am chief bottle washer.
So I'm very comfortable here.
But to be a member of the get on top,
he Mitchell,
you have to mess it up.
Is that okay?
So I'm very,
I'm very happy there is that.
Okay.
But there are tree roots.
The first word is you're not allowed waitress half as a person.
Second road is you're not allowed to accept anybody else's rating of you as a
person.
But the third one is you are allowed to Rachel behavior but not true.
Andrew scares but not yourself.
What a wonderful case to be.
Now the wreck,
it comes from a cartoon series in the 80s Rod,
is it a,
does it?
We've been there as a working perfect of a trend to me,
Jack,
then it's like a tired,
we called the rejects from so as high tech by my,
uh,
for mental health.
Is that,
okay?
So I have hundreds of cars at carry ragged on tobacco.
The guys won't carry ragged [inaudible] you know what I mean?
Is that okay?
But what it does,
it,
it kind of as a way of believe or not,
I never have a problem with a person with depression who comes into me and raced
themselves a team.
They had grabbed a rag down.
Basically my problems are the high achievers,
the people that come in and read and have some 95 or 97 and then dropped to 90
and the can't handles.
I remember one protector guy said to me,
what do you mean I can't,
I can't bathe myself.
I live for my rating.
That's all I live for.
I said,
well why here?
In other words,
if you were,
if you're winning after written,
why have you come to see me?
Because we actually don't win a race and we just put us out in this fashion.
Interesting.
That's really insightful.
I think we probably have time for maybe two questions.
Nope.
Okay,
great.
Thank you.
Um,
[inaudible] like I have a collection of off something that I think I read
correctly.
It will say that suicide is driven by the logic side of brain and nope,
what happens in suicide.
It could be wants to do what happens to the stereotype is that a part of rain or
is completely negative and we start to have this room and if we call and those
women they agree to talks about that.
I,
uh,
a fair number one,
but the one that kills people,
the one that really distressed as people is that they begin to believe that this
incredible distress that they're feeding will never end and that they're the
failure for letting it happen.
So the only way they can get rid of this incredible distress,
which is by the way,
the ruminations are going on in our head,
is actually to take the wrong knife.
And that's incredibly constant from survivors.
Do you know what I mean?
They can over there today,
and it doesn't matter whether you,
uh,
you are thinking of taking your own life because of depression or because of
shame,
because of something terrible has happened to you and you've been phoned out,
uh,
or whether his financial problems,
it's that you get so that you believe that the problem is in solvable by any
other means.
And it's going on night and day in your head and it caused a terrible distress.
Won't go where you get to the point where I can put up into distress any longer.
It's not that you want today is you want to stop to distress,
distress,
distress is your emotional mind.
Do you know what I mean?
That's your emotional mind.
Now,
that's coming from an emotional,
but what actually happens is the,
normally there's a kind of a check balance coming from the logical mind.
Do you know what I mean?
Eh.
So your logical mind normally keeps your emotion mind in check,
but once it turns negative,
it swamps the logical brain and the logic brain just can't get a look at.
And that's what happens.
And when the person makes and attempt and surveys,
very often they're on the snapped back to kind of a situation where their
logical brain and maybe has a better chance of being reengaged to do,
particularly if the get some help.
But if they don't get,
have to revert back to where they were.
You know what I mean?
It's a very,
very good question.
Final question.
What's
really interesting talk you were talking about social anxiety gets how you can
deal with it yourself.
My question is more relationship,
how you deal with people that are arranging with social anxiety and I think your
first urge is to want to push them into these types of situations.
I'm just wondering like doing nice.
Yeah.
It won't work.
It,
it's a bit like
if,
for example,
you have a person with a motorway and phobia,
you can get them onto the motorway of,
unless you understand what's happened to them and what's going to happen and how
would you deal with it,
they're never going to be confident they're going to meet today and the next
time next manager turned around and going to become,
if you force the press where it's social anxiety into social situations to get
worse because they need the help,
the need to techniques.
But the good news is that once they understand what's going on and do some of my
famous embarrassment exercise very quickly,
they grab what's actually happening to him in social situations and you just
give them a few little techniques and skills and the drive.
Do you know what I mean?
So I think that they,
they,
they really,
uh,
north lot of people will benefit from say reading the book,
looking at the videos and if necessary,
going for a little bit of how it,
because to be honest with you,
it,
if you get to the right person,
this can be sorted out really,
really fast.
Do you know what I mean?
And uh,
but never push it person social anxiety because it won't be all dirty work.
Thank you for that.
Do you have,
has a question.
Hey,
you're our last one.
Thank you for that.
Um,
just a quick,
why is it so quick to actually retrain the brain in a couple of sessions and,
well,
I suppose by the time a person,
usually you say w would come to see me,
they are really anxious.
If you want a person like that to actually need to do something about it.
Um,
I think what,
when we say it's,
it's not so much that it's quick,
but if they did that,
when I give them exercises,
they have to keep repeating those exercise over and over again.
Do you know what I mean?
And the thing about the brain is the brand,
the first time doesn't get it or gets it a little bit.
The second time it gets a little bit.
The third time it's getting it more for time is getting it more by the time you
had done a 10 times as we need.
Got It.
So that's the way the brain works.
If you think about it,
if you are trying to learn the skill,
for example,
learning how to drive a car,
you don't cringe at the car,
get some techniques and go and drive the car.
You practice and you make mistakes and you're practicing to make mistakes.
But gradually you find you're getting happier and happier and suddenly becomes
instinctive.
And that's what happens in your brain.
We call that neuroplasticity the ability to change your brain pathways and the
good news is that something like do you make of the changes almost instantly,
you know really quickly so you can turn him around quite quickly.
But social things I used because it's involving tracks between your,
your emotions and your logical brain takes a little bit longer.
Do you know what I mean?
You have to do a bit more work,
but I'm going be twice so quick because he's a very,
he's a,
he's a tech Oregon.
He's very basic kid.
He doesn't get it,
you know,
so he,
he,
his job,
if you can imagine the guy is talking to the love is somewhere with headphones
on and somebody shows danger when he does pass fire.
Do you know what I mean?
So somebody says don't the dangerous.
So he does a danger,
you know,
he,
he doesn't really think it out,
but he actually,
he actually don't play us very quickly.
And it's really interesting to see this in practice by the way.
The thing or is really important in depression as well.
He's probably the major cause of depression because for example,
the colleague,
a friend of mine from [inaudible] remarks verge,
she,
for example,
they just fascinating experiment where she took all of these people with
depression and scanned or a link to this responses to something negative doing
twin negative fifth.
And actually what was really interesting was that a bit by bit,
or when she was doing our scanning,
she knows that every salary person there and make it as overactive,
every solitary one when they got some treatment for a week even.
Do you know what I mean?
That even,
even though their depression was lifted,
she could actually tell the ones that we're going to improve.
The ones that are working on improved cause they're making it went back to
normal.
So not fascinating.
This protector take Oregon,
unfortunately,
is pretty important in our life and it causes most of the difficulties there.
They're nice,
but he is very,
very transparent.
That's ramping here.
Talk Safari.
Unfortunately,
we're out of time.
I know it's more effective for you as I'm sure our audience,
Debo.
Dan,
thank you very much.
[inaudible].